قصه من الخيال بس واقعيه 32 عاما كل لحظه
فيها كانها عام كامل لكن كل هذا انتهى مع
اللقاء بعد الفراق بالفعل قصتنا اليوم
مشاهدينا عن الشاب السعودي خالد السنيد
الذي عاش لي اكثر من ثلاثه عقود دون
والدته المصريه بعد انفصالها عن والده
وانقطاع اخبارها خالد كبوره ولم يتخلى عن
حلمه بلقاء والدته التي لم يعيش معها
كثيرا
لذلك سنوات طويله واخيرا كان اللقاء الذي
انهى كل سنين الثنائي والبعد الفعل ولقاء
جميل جمع الابن بوالدته وطغت الفرحه
ودموعها على كل شيء واليوم في صباح
العربيه سنكون معهما لنبارك لهما هذا
الاجتماع مجددا
لنسمع قصه الفراق الصعبه
الحمد لله مبروك مبروك
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
والحمد لله
[موسيقى]
نشاهد مؤثره جدا بالفعل مشاهدينا احنا
معنا الان من الاسكندريه عبير حنفي الامه
المصريه ومعنا من الرياض تركي الاسناد
طبعا الابن يعني مش عارفين كيف بدنا نبارك
لكم ونهنيكم بهذا اللقاء بعد 30 عام وطبعا
احنا شايفين
يعني الدموع في عيونكم وبصراحه ادمعتونا
احنا ايضا الف مبروك طبعا على اجتماعكم
بعد ثلاث عقود من الزمن وخلي لي ابلش معك
ست عبير من الاسكندريه التعبير انت يعني
هل حاولتي انك تحاولي تعثري على ابنك كل
هذه السنين وكيف كان شعورك لما اجاك الخبر
والتليفون بانه هو موجود وعم بدور عليك
وبده يشوفك
السلام عليكم انا كنت كنت دايما بتصل بيه
باهله
كنت على طول بسال عليه بتصل بالتليفون
محدش بيرضى يديني ويقولوا لي لا احنا قلنا
له ان انت متي فما كانش ما كانش يعني ما
كانش ينفع ان انا اكلمه يقولوا لي لا ما
ينفعش احنا قلنا له ان انت متي فانا ما
ينفعش ان انت تكلميه
فكنت دايما اقول لهم
طب اسمع صوتهم مش هقول لهم ان انا مش هقول
له ان انا امه بس اسمع صوته
كان برضو في رفض منهم
فعشان كنت عاوزه اروح السفاره بس ادام هم
رافضين ما ينفعش ان انا اروح السفاره
طيب يعني لما شفتيه انا انا ابي هذا هذا
الواقع لما شفتيه اول مره بعد ثلاثين سنه
ثلاثه عقود وانت وهو بعيد عنك ايه المشاعر
كيف عرفتي اول شيء عرفت ازاي
انا ما كنتش مصدقه في الاول ان هو قالوا
لي ان ابنك ابنك جه وتدور عليك ولقياك فما
كنتش مصدقه اكننا في حلم يعني شعور فرحه
مع ان انا مش مصدقه ده فعلا حقيقه يعني ده
انا مش دي حقيقه اللي بتحصل دي مش مصدقه
طيب احنا الدموع الصادقه اكيد مقدرينها
احنا
عن جد يعني مقدرين هذه المشاعر
وحاسين معكم وحاسين فيكم طيب تركي انا بدي
اسالك يعني انت كيف كيف قدرت توصل وكيف
عرفت بانه والدتك يعني على قيد الحياه كيف
قدرت تعرف مكانها وشو كان شعورك بهديك
اللحظه
قررت عينك يا تركي يا تركي
مرحبا يا مرحبا صباح الخير حياكم الله هلا
ومرحبا
كيف الحال سامعني يا تركي
كنت عم بسالك عن كيف عرفت تفضل تفضل
احكي لنا القصه كيف وجدتها وقديش قعدت
تدور سنين وانت تدور عليه
سنين وانا ادور وشعور يعني الحمد لله او
بالبدايه ما كنت مصدق هل انا هو حلم او
انه صح او انه مو بهذا الشيء لكن الحمد
لله اني وصلت عن طريق السفاره السعوديه
جهزوا كل شيء بالنسبه لي
الله يجزاهم خير على سعاده السفير اشكر له
يعني يعني الجهات الرسميه او السفاره
السعوديه في القاهره هي سهلت لك ايضا
مهمتك تركيبي الوصول الى والدتك
لهم فضل كبير
للوصول الوالده انا كنت ابحث قبل
كنت ابحث قبل لكن ما قدرت اوصل يعني كلها
من كلام وكنت ابحث من عنده قاربي ما حد
وصلني لها فاضطريت اني اروح للسفاره فما
لي حل الا السفاره دخلت عليهم كان اول يوم
دوام بعد العيد بعد عيد الفطر
استقبلوني ورحبوا فيني
واخذوا موضوع يعني كان مهم مره
مدير شلون مدير شؤون الرعايه السعوديه
استاذ محمد البريكي والاستاذ ونابه
الاستاذ محمد السبيعي
والمستشار الفني
المستشار القانوني مجدي محفوظ على راسهم
السفير اسامه نقلي كلهم والله ما قصروا
معي من ناحيه انهم لقوا الوالده وابحثوا
عنها بالبدايه الى الملف الصحي حقها يعني
او فيها اي شيء
[موسيقى]
بعدين تم الترتيب مع
ابنك ايه في خله يطلع ويانا وانت تحضره
فهد عسى الله يحفظك
وتيته عبير انت لسه ما التقيتي بعائلته
لتركي بابنائه وزوجته
لانه شفت مراته وبشكر مراته بشكر وشفت
ابنه شفتهم يعني كده في التليفون انما ما
قابلتهمش اعز من الوالده الوالده الولد
استاذ عبير او سيده عبير
حتربي احفاده دلوقتي ان شاء الله
ان شاء الله تلتقيهم يعني وجها لوجه طيب
الان
المستقبل
المستقبل بعد ما ضاع 30 سنه من من يعني من
هذا الوقت الثمين اللي اي ابن بقضيه مع
والدته المستقبل الان قديه راح تلتقوا
قديه راح تقدوا اوقات مع بعض حتى نعوض
السنين اللي فاتت
ان شاء الله هذا شيء اكيد وان شاء الله
اني بحاول اني اجيبها للسعوديه عندي واروح
لها واجي يعني هذا الشيء بحاول اني اعوضها
عن كل اللي فاتت والله يقدرني ان شاء الله
واسعدها ويخليها لي ويطول بعمرها يعني هذا
الشيء اللي كنت او من بدايه حياتي وهو
ناقصني انه وجود امي جنبي وجود حنانها
وعطفه علي
ما شافتني وانا كبرت وانا صغير بكل جميع
المراحل عمري حتى لما تزوجت كنت اتمنى
انها تكون معي موجوده بعد ما ربي رزقني
بمولود
مره احتجت اني اوصل لها باي طريق باي
وسيله من الوسل فما بالي والله السفاره
السعوديه
والحمد لله والله كلهم ما قصروا واشكرهم
كلهم من على راسهم السفير اسامه نقلي
وجميع العاملين
طيب انا انا والله وقتنا انتهى لكن لازم
اسالكم انا مقدر هذه الدموع لكن انا بودي
انا اسال يعني اليوم تركي انه 30 عام وانت
بعيد شو اللي راح ترسمه في مخيلتك
للمستقبل
الله يحفظ لك والدتك والله يرحم امهات
اللي ما عندهم والده
اللهم امين هذا شعور بدون الام الحاله
انا في البدايه اصلا ما كنت مصدق حتى لما
كلمتها في التلفون ما كنت مصدق مره بعد ما
كلمتها وسمعت صوتها اضطريت اني ابعد شوي
واحبس نفسي لمده عشر دقائق ابغى اتاكد هل
هو صح اللي انا فيه حلم علم لاني تقريبا
شبه فوق الى العشره سنين وانا ادور فشيء
متعب مره نفسيا
صعبه جدا الحمد لله ان ربي يجمعني
من الله
وطبعا اشكر مولاي خادم الحرمين الشريفين
ولي عهد الامين الامير محمد بن سلمان
واشكر السفاره السعوديه على كل اللي سواه
معي
وسعاده السفير اسامه نقلي
والاستاذ محمد البريكي والاستاذ محمد
السبيعي له فضل كبير بعد الله عندي لانه
انسان والله احنا نشكرك ونقول نقول تركي
دائما يقولون الدموع دموع الرجال عزيزه
لكن المواقف يعني مواقف الام هي تنزل
الدموع شكرا جزيلا لترك الاثنين من الرياض
والشكر موصول لوالدته عبير حنفي شكرا
جزيلا لكم وعسى الله يبارك لكم هذا اللقاء
ان شاء الله
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات